on comprend pas bien ses rythmes
saisonniers mais chez nous c'est vrai
qu'il ya une saisonnalité
tous les virus respiratoires non pas les
mêmes saisonnalité je vous parlais de
par l'influencé 3 c'est le printemps et
l'automne
c'est pas l'hiver d'accord donc si par
analogie fort c'est à dire écoutez
comment à quoi ça va ressembler
analogiquement le sar ce premier hop ça
il ya une pique et puis ça s'est arrêté
en juillet lors qu'il ya plus de cas du
tout et on a plus depuis
d'accord les autres coronavirus qui
s'est passé c'est que il ya un moment
probablement n'a pas su quand est ce
qu'on les a découvert un peu par hasard
les autres coronavirus endémique et bien
il ya probablement une diffusion qui
s'est fait un peu partout dans le monde
parce que lui est partout au tour par
tour on trouve en afrique on entend
partout en chine et donc il le il s'est
installé maintenant durablement avec
nous et il a une d'épidémie mais au jeu
saisonnière avec quelques cas
sporadiques pendant le reste de l'année
et donc c'est les deux modèles que je
connais de coronavirus tant que demander
jeu qui écoute et voilà dans les modèles
que je connais c'est que là donc les
chances que ça ressemble au modèle qu'on
connaît déjà mais peut-être que ce sera
quelque chose de totalement différent
parce que c'est une autre maladie est
une nouvelle maladie et là en plus il
est en train de se passer les choses que
moi j'avais pas vu décrite en tout cas
avec les coronavirus et la vitesse de
mutation qu'il a actuellement et donc je
ne sais pas ce qui va devenir ce matin
on nous a dit qu'il semblait que le
virus ne mute et pas je sais pas qui a
quoi moi je sais ce que j'ai moi donc je
pense qu'on fait plus de séquences que
n'importe qui ont fait énormément de
séquencer dans des conditions d'ailleurs
je obligé de faire venir les gens le
week-end pour pouvoir continuer à faire
les séquences donc on a fait à peu près
500 séquence de virus depuis juillet
parce qu on était étonnés de voir la
forme que prenaient les cas cliniques et
l'épidémie depuis juillet le paraissait
différentes donc on avait et dès le
départ on a trouvé un mutant qu'on a
appelée marseille qui est assez online
vous pouvez les regarder qui est assez
qui présentait plus de mutations que ce
qu'on avait l'habitude de voir et 23
buts à sion par rapport aux la souche de
yuan
donc on pensait qu réellement et celui
là on a retracé sa source
c'est à dire
venus du maghreb sur les bateaux et tous
les premiers cas ont été vraiment lié à
ça et ensuite une diffusion qui s'est
passé dans l'environnement on a eu 100
cas de ce virus là actuellement ce
virus-là à peu près disparu depuis août
et ont pensé que c'est lui qui avait
plus le truc et on a maintenant 7 mi
temps
celui qui est le plus celui qui est le
plus actif actuellement c'est ce qu'on
appelait katroun à 60 cartes du 4 et
globalement si vous voulez si vous
regardez le nom mais vous voyez bien
quand on peut pas parler de la même
chose moi je vous assure c'est des
données je viens de les écrire qu'à les
regarder son online parce que mon mais
effectivement c'est une deux au
traitement mais tout cela est maintenant
en particulier à des situations
épidémiques pour que tout le monde
puisse en profiter
si on regarde nous tous les virus que
nous avons eu jusqu'en mai il compte on
regarde leurs deux si vous regardez sur
notre site vous le verrez on a beaucoup
réfléchi pour leur présenter de manière
qui est visible sert sur un cercle
le degré de variation par rapport à la
souche initial
si vous regardez la différence entre les
différentes souches que nous avions par
rapport à la souche initial elle donnait
un cercle diamètre x si vous regardez
maintenant ce que nous avons depuis
juillet ce ce diamètre a été multiplié
par dix c'est à dire la variabilité des
virus que nous avons maintenant les
virus que nous avons maintenant son
antre présente entre eux dix fois plus
de variations que les virus que nous
avions jusqu'en mai et c'est des
variations qui sont très intéressantes
parce que sont des variations convoi
dans la dégradation des génomes en
général c'est à dire c'est d'aider des
variations c'est qu'à quatre bases dans
les génétique
qui sont intéressés pour l'adn et pour
les virus à arn la place d'un thé vous
avez eu et donc la dégradation de ces
verrues est une normalement et réparer
parce que la plupart du temps est
délétère et donc là ce convoi
majoritairement c'est des mutations de
tv rue qui traduisent soit l'effet d'une
enzyme qui est bien connu chez les
humains qui s'appelle à pour beck qui a
l'habitude de couper les virus donc
peut-être qu'au fur et à mesure que ce
virus s'est répandu et est arrivée des
formes qui qui est qui qui permettent la
transformation de ces verrues soit il
est donc soit il se passe quelque chose
dans ce virus qui permet ça mais ce que
je peux vous dire leur sens là aussi
étudié peut-être que delfraissy n'y a
pas vu encore mais moi je les ai vus
parce qu'on a envoyé le papier on a
comparé 100 cas à partir de juillet et
ce en paca avant pour regarder quel
était le degré de leurs troubles de
coagulation et donc ils ont beaucoup
moins de troubles de coagulation ils
sont moins sévères et la mortalité est
plus faible
donc il se passe quelque chose avec ce
lyrisme qui en fait quelque chose de
différent voilà